con falsas promesas y engaños el lunes
20 migrantes irregulares llegaron a esta
parroquia en Sacramento California sin
saber exactamente qué hacían allí fueron
transportados desde el Paso Texas por
representantes de un contratista privado
Con promesas de trabajo y alojamiento
mientras esperaban la resolución de su
petición de asilo se montaron en un
avión privado sin saber el destino los
dejaron enfrente de la sede de la
Iglesia Católica Romana de la ciudad
californiana sin explicación alguna y
sin previo aviso a las autoridades
eclesiásticas
no teníamos ni idea que iban a venir
Pero mi equipo no tardó en encontrar a
algunos de los miembros de nuestra
comunidad que trabajan con inmigrantes
los migrantes llevaban documentos que
indicaban que su transporte involucraba
al Estado de la Florida por lo que las
autoridades californianas creen que la
gobernación de ron de santis podría
estar detrás del hecho Gaby newson se
refiere al caso registrado en septiembre
de 2022 cuando el gobierno de ronde
Santi se envió más de 40 migrantes a una
isla de Massachusetts Aunque les habían
prometido llevarlos a Boston donde
supuestamente los esperaban con trabajo
comida y dinero sin embargo todo era
mentira Entonces cuando llegamos acá no
nos encontramos sorprendidos porque
buscamos a la gente de acá de la isla de
Marta la gente nos vio como confundido
Quiénes son ustedes y nosotros Quiénes
son ustedes también entonces quedamos
como ninguno sabíamos que era Nadie
Ellos no sabían la causa por la que
nosotros veníamos Nosotros tampoco
sabíamos la causa por la que llegamos
hasta el momento del gobierno de Florida
no ha declarado al respecto pero la
fiscalía californiana sigue las
investigaciones